ali vous faites partie vous êtes les des
petites clés petite série de vidéos sur
internet pour montrer que vous pouvez
chanter dans n'importe quelle situation
sous l'eau sous le vent en vous faisant
chatouiller le corps regardez ça
alors étant donné vous faites ça et vite
et nous ici on voulait faire le champ de
l'extrême venez avec moi
ali jean michel mr et nora venez là
c'est très simple dieu vous dire vous
allez enlever vos chaussures enlevées
aux socios jean michel bayle était
charles v à vos chaussures ali
al-essaoui les chaussettes les
chaussures vous allez mettre vos pieds
donc dans ces bacs où on va découvrir
vous allez voir il ya des choses un
petit peu spéciale dans les bacs vous
avez démarré avec ce bac c'est jean
michel maire qui va démarrer dans ce bac
ensuite ali sera dont celui-là et enora
voilà vous serez dans celui du bist vous
allez chanter vous allez chanter avec
vos pieds dans dans une bassine ceux des
matières un petit peu particulière jean
michel maire vous allez démarrer alors
attention jean-michel j'enlève samedi 20
c'est quoi ça c'est pas messieurs c'est
décidé on ça c'est ça c'est le bac de la
mer c'est du poulpe c'est du bruit en
dehors donc allez-y
jean michel maire vous allez dans son
site optimisé mais ça prouve à dimanche
et vous avez marre des crs
jean-michel mais allez-y donc allez
c'est parti
jean-michel qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
sentez larusso tout est bien d'accord la
caméra et la regarder elle est là oui
merci je sais pas ce qu'ils voient la
caméra publiera tous les jours tout ce
temps de que se réveille un matin des
bras autour de mon cou
l amour que l'on faisait n'importe où tu
oublieras tout le mal que tu as en me
regardant souffrir ces instants
difficiles dont je ne sais plus quoi
dire si les sourires
mais la peau si vous êtes à la limite
c'est à vous prenez ce bac qualité si
c'est le hasard
on m'a dit ali bach 1 voilà les
attentions alors là vous voyez si c'est
que je dois mes chauffeurs s'il te plaît
c'est le talent on va vous l'enlever on
va vous l'enlever et on vous mettra
après vous allez chanter avec des
serpents sur les pieds vous inquiétez
pas c'est que des serpents qui viennent
de la maison c'est tous mes amis il ya
tous les cousins la voile alors allez-y
allez vous avez vous senti quoi c'est
plus que jamais si vous ne voulez pas je
n'ai pas peur mais sinon alors alors
attention allez on y va
je crois vous allez nous chanter je sais
plus d'ailleurs il était mon titre nina
simone ou votre titre alesi sûreté votre
titre attention alléger la mettez vous
en ai déjà qu'ils étaient passés tour
des poules ils sont déjà pris ça ils
sont prêts à l'elysée tonton et la voilà
c'est bon ça arrive ce moyen à léger
portier musée c'est pas vrai j'ai rester
digne allez à lysiane vous voulez faire
a capella ou voulez un petit peu de
musique derrière
j'aimais ce fait ça peut être
tous les to date
à
toulouse toulouse le 10 sport comprenant
des voix la balle est là elle est bien à
l'est libyen attali ziani parquet et
partez ali merci à lee bravo à enora et
nora qui va nous chanter là et que poyet
de madonna je voulais je vous connais
d'ailleurs
demos sur le paillasson nom m'échappe
mais y'a rien regarder n'a rien n'à rien
n'a rien d'ici là les aidera à les
hémorragies mettez vos p alors vous avez
une chaufferie like flyers de madonna y
en avait un il n'y avait rien là vient
vous n'avez rien à vous tous à l'esprit
des gens tu sais rien céder versé mais
pas du tout c'est rien c'est que des
bonnes choses
elle va commencer à chanter on aura
commencé à chanter madonna on lui mettra
je le mettrais ma main c'est un message
fort et et jean-michel ça les ai
commencé à céder commencé à chanter de
plus à l'est
il ne met pas
c
ak non
sympa vous percez bravo à michel bras
merci merci et bravo mais c'est rien
c'est l'ascension de l'ecstasy au pays
restait pas là vous allez me sall au
passage merci applaudissements floralies
aussi dilater version alpha bel et bien
sûr la rabasse et tout ça et on n'a rien
on n'a pas fait de mal au serpent le
cheval et les séquelles et peut déjà
déçu mais les pieuvres elles sont ou 30
at in et un mauvais c'était quand même
avant la sélection elles sont réelles et
évitent assurez vous n'avez pas les
manger
sachez le tout était voilà voilà donc
merci on merci en tout cas merci annie
bercy enora et merci aujourd'hui seuls
verts